i want to jump to a totally unrelated
story because it's friday and we haven't
talked about this all week alec baldwin
could go to prison criminal charges
still possible in rust shooting sheriff
says and i just want to highlight that
alec baldwin
my understanding is that he told the
police he knows the difference between
dummy rounds and live rounds but that he
did not check the gun himself
we then saw the footage that got
released because everyone was wondering
like hey they filmed alec baldwin doing
this where's the footage and you can see
that ella baldwin lied he said my finger
was not on the trigger and you can see
in this footage they released his
fingers on the trigger every time that
doesn't mean his fingers on the trigger
the time he actually fired it but
come on if i'm gonna have to make a bet
his finger was on the trigger here's the
best part about all this
when al when people point out that alec
baldwin jack was at this he's like alec
baldwin should not be talking to these
cops without lawyers because he
basically admitted to doing it
people are like yeah but he's an actor
this is what i hear from every single
person on the left for some reason
wanted to defend alec baldwin he was on
set doing was supposed to do it's not
his fault
please
pull up the manslaughter provision and i
think what was it new mexico
show me where it says actors get a
special exemption from involuntary
manslaughter
it doesn't exist if you are handed a gun
and you point at a person and you pull
the hammer back of a single action
revolver and it fires that's involuntary
manslaughter textbook yeah also what an
unbelievably stupid excuse like
you know if someone's filming you and
you point a gun at someone and pull the
trigger i guess you can't be prosecuted
because you're an actor i'm making a
movie
could you imagine there's like a serial
killer and he's got a camera guy with
him the whole time making a movie she's
filming a prank show where they go
around and stab people to death it was a
prank bro so so just for fun i'm gonna
go against every instinct i have
and i'm gonna i'm gonna argue the other
side of this
so you're in a position where you're
handed a gun and that gun is supposed to
be loaded with with blanks for the scene
because obviously
sorry dummies because it want to be you
know loaded with live rounds
uh there's no reasonable expectation
that would be loaded with live rounds um
and this is a scene that you've done
this is something you've done before and
so you do it this time and this time oh
my gosh there's a live round in it
and that's where it goes into the
involuntary manslaughter point it's like
okay you've got obviously we're not
talking about you know necessarily like
premeditated murder you know anything
like that
um
i i can there's a part of me that can
understand like okay i i this is a part
of my job this is what i do this is how
it works and i did it this way and
something tragic happened i'm more
concerned about again how did a live
round get into that
and then
why did why did she get even with a
dummy round because here's the other
there's the other part that i think a
lot of people don't understand about
this is they think oh i'm firing a blank
okay well there's there's differences
between firing a blank i mean there have
been hollywood stars that have died
because of a blank because of the
wadding yeah was it uh brandon lee
brandon leader two people
and that other guy in the 80s who
pointed the blank to his head and killed
himself yeah and they just they don't
understand how some of this works now
alec baldwin's been doing this for a
while 40 years and he should understand
how it works and that's the part where a
little bit more culpability for me
creeps into this
i don't care uh who you are
if you are handed a gun
and then you point it at somebody and
kill them you're in trouble no there's a
question so alec baldwin trying to use
this actor excuse where it's like well
someone else was handling the gun
i don't care and people are like
i tweeted about this and they're like
here's someone who's never been on set
before and i'm like dude all you're
telling me is that the people on set are
idiots yeah they are they were in that
movie um gutierrez reed hannah the the
arm what was she the hannah gutierrez
reed yeah she's the basically not the
arms master but in charge of the weapons
she's not the one that handed the gun to
alec i'm pretty sure she wasn't even on
set there's video of her from the day if
you guys haven't seen this video it's
all over the place now there's all this
video right after the shooting and she's
like
did they tell him they tell hannah that
that alec fired away and she's like alec
baldwin alec baldwin had the gun yeah oh
my god and like she had no idea what was
going on someone basically in my
estimation there were a bunch of people
that quit walked off the set they said
it's un unsafe someone loaded that gun
knowing that alec was gonna pull it out
not check because he's a lazy whatever
and that's exactly what happened i think
someone put that in there so that he
would do the killing
let me clarify something i'm not saying
that he's not criminally liable what i'm
saying is is that when when i first
heard about this i'm like okay an actor
did something stupid with a gun not a
shock
um
it is there is there any sort of
reasonable from a legal perspective is
there any sort of reasonable argument to
be made that hey
i was supposed to get a gun to do this i
was supposed to point and put and pull
the trigger and do this i did that and
then something happened that i did not
intend now the other side of this is
going back to your point someone hands
you a gun the way i grew up the what i
was taught is you are now responsible
for everything that gun does and you
don't get to say well this person handed
it to me that's the part where the
culpability creeps back in every every
time i've done an ex like a handoff for
any weapon the same thing occurs
the magazine is taken out you clear it
make sure there's nothing in it then you
lock the bolt back the hammer or
whatever and then you hand it pointed
down you follow all the rules and i
don't even consider myself a gun expert
i just have guns so i'm like it's not
even an issue of
proper protocol it's like i'm not i'm
gonna i'm gonna check my firearms and
i'm gonna make sure it's clearly visible
that there's nothing in it i'm handing
it to you and it will still be treated
as if it's loaded even with the magazine
removed
alec baldwin when they when they're on
movie sets and people are acting like
it's normal to be handed a weapon that's
that's sealed potentially loaded and
you're like i trust them
the weapon from the people on set
i'm told if they're supposed to open it
show you the rounds take them out
explain what they are put them back
close it and then hand it to you with
all safety protocols happening before
your eyes yeah alec baldwin was supposed
to go through that check then have the
weapon and that's why he would not open
the weapon up and check alec baldwin
claimed he's like if i were to open it
up and mess with it they would stop the
chute because that would be tampering
with a weapon and i'm not allowed to do
it only the armorer is yes but the armor
are supposed to go up to you show you
the mechanism show you the safety take
it open it up let you know take out the
magazine clear it and say everything's
here it's it's unloaded i've showed it
to you now you're responsible for it
they didn't do that so alec baldwin
received a weapon did not check he's
responsible oh no he's checking i would
also argue that the person that was
responsible for doing that so for
instance if if someone handed him a
weapon and said here's your weapon for
the senate he did it he's still
responsible because he didn't follow the
protocol they're also responsible
because they didn't follow the protocol
i don't know
so this this assistant director i guess
is the guy who handed him the gun
but
they're on set he's he's he's got a gun
he says it's for alec
it's not his job to check it that's true
so i don't actually know if that guy
would have any responsibility the
responsibility is if alec baldwin knows
he's receiving a weapon that guy isn't
the one who pointed it and pulled the
trigger no no no that i'm not arguing
with that yeah that's yeah so alec
baldwin involuntary manslaughter
prison he's also the producer of the
movie oh there's another
he should have been overseeing the
safety mechanisms the armor should have
been there if they're handling live
weapons
when i was in the military we would we
would go to the range we'd do our thing
then we'd also go to like what we call
shoot houses
and within our shoot houses we're
practicing close quarters battle so
you're you're doing high intensity
explosives um you know hostage rescue
the whole deal you'd go from you'd do
live rounds at some point you'd also do
what we called sim rounds so some rounds
had a different barrel for your your m4
and your m9
and they fired paint rounds you would
shoot each other with the paint rounds
now again you weren't shooting a live
round through those sim barrels but
we went through so many checks and
processes when you were when you were
transitioning from i've been doing some
rounds to live rounds right you did so
many processes to do that
and and if you screwed up it was on you
because at the end of the day you're
still responsible for what's going on at
that range i mean you can you can point
to a ranged safety officer and they
might get in trouble as well
but ultimately you're still responsible
for what happens with the firearm in
your hands
yeah that's the way it's got to be
moving forward unless you're an actor
well yeah
no you're still responsible as an actor
no i know he killed that woman man
vladimir putin is filming a movie
oh in ukraine yeah why he's there right
now yeah he was just filming a movie
movie with russian troops right the
troops just it's it's it's it's set crew
man it's all for the energy also all set
crew they're just there to uh film a war
flick and uh all of the civilians and
all destruction well i mean i feel like
that blame putin it's a movie with alec
it's not even that i hate the guy i just
feel like justice has to be served it'd
be the same if it was my brother that
did it
my brother in his position and he killed
somebody same thing he's got to serve
justice like that you can't just let
people get away with that or they're
going to do it again and again you got
to stop it in its tracks yeah everyone's
been predicting that he's going to pay
some settlement to the family and
nothing's going to happen
probably wow why should he get in
trouble because he killed somebody well
i know that but i mean like in their
mind they're thinking like well you know
i love the conspiracies the conspiracy
theories though that the woman was like
an investigative reporter and they
whenever something weird happens you get
the conspiracy theorists you're tied all
into like this grand hollywood
conspiracy careful that it's not like an
alex jones uh what do they call it sandy
hook thing where someone's like she's a
this and then the family comes after you
with try with a civil suit yeah i don't
talk crap about people when they're dead
no you shouldn't talk crap about private
citizens with things that aren't true
yeah especially when there's emotional
emotions involved like death the truth
shall set you free you know alex alex
jones's issue is that he said things
that weren't true about private
individuals that had been killed that
was a big part of it no it's the
families he was talking about who's
making fun of people who are still alive
oh yeah they were not making fun of he
was making statements about them so i
just i just say um you know in these in
these circumstances
you know he always wanted to have the
truth you always want to have your facts
he also shot a dude in the shoulder he
he killed a girl and then wounded
another guy oh that's the the director
if you watch the video it's crazy
he's
i don't know man it's crazy someone set
him up that is nasty i i don't i don't
know if i agree i all those people that
hated him on that set and then all of a
sudden there's a bullet shows up in the
gun he's using like and maybe he put it
there maybe maybe but i didn't seem
realistic i just think that you have to
make assumptions to assume it wasn't him
yeah i do you're right it's no way to
know it's it's the simpler solution
albeit sounds crazy that alec put the
bullet in there
well either way it's an
assumption was holding a gun and the gun
went off and killed someone
from the only that's the only thing we
need to know
where the bullet came from as far as i'm
concerned alec baldwin is responsible
when you see his finger on the trigger
when he's pulling the gun in practice in
rehearsal he's got his finger on the
trigger and then he's like my finger
wasn't on the trigger like dude he's
lying trigger and the crazy thing too is
one of the reasons i actually think what
we're seeing now lends to the idea that
alec is guilty of just outright homicide
is that the way he was holding it he
could have shot himself
no i think he knew it was in that gun
he was it was it was in his it was in
his uh chest hole holster you pointed
out you can't assume you don't shouldn't
assume well the thing always the thing
is there's three things that detective
looks for on this it's right method um
motive and opportunity
so we we obviously know that all of it
we know the opportunity i don't know
what the motive is the motive was that
the crew was was yelling at him and
fighting with him
and it was stated uh this is this is
viva fry did a really good job bring
this down that hutchins was aggravating
was very aggressive with alec that she
wasn't supposed to be directing him she
was a cinematographer alec had already
explained that he was frustrated we know
he's temperamental we know that the
staff on the set have been complaining
and threatening to walk off
he's been dealing with the whole time
and now he gets this woman who's bossing
him around he's pissed off
he had a motive there's another guy on
the set they interviewed and he's like i
don't wanna i don't wanna
throw anyone under the bus but let's
just say the practices on that set were
not
safe
and it's like he's basically what he's
saying is they're shooting live rounds
for fun on set but he didn't come out
and say that he didn't name names but
it's like he was a guy working on the
movie basically saying they weren't
following safety protocol thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you